times where you know i don't i bomb all
the time were you really a pt
yeah yeah i still am i i go the great
governor cuomo
from new york just um
just uh in the beginning of the pandemic
he reinstated every health
professional's license that had lapsed
because of the pandemic or whatever
because we were you know physical
therapists would
became important for like respiratory
therapy so my license had laps because i
stopped doing physical therapy in 2013
and then i think
it lapsed in like 2018 and i never
reinstated it because i've been you know
just doing
this full-time but then i got a letter
in the mail that was like hey
you're licensed you can go treat
physical now i've my license
is good so i think 2024. so i'm like
technically still
a lot i but do you know the move still i
was a pediatric physical therapist
mostly so i could work on you because
you have little
little body parts but you know somebody
with with with bigger feet no wait wait
wait
what like kalila i would have to i would
have would have
those beautiful big feet but yes
i'm pediatric what does that mean it
means you're a baby baby because you're
because your body's smaller
you look like most of the children i
treated with down syndrome that that
they would work with yes it's true
all right don't put that out i want
people to know that
i think that's sexy one of the throat
out there down syndrome
yeah the the children children who have
down syndrome beautiful population of
children
yeah to work with they one of the things
with down syndrome is yes
bigger bigger tongues from the
chromosomal deficiencies you're saying
that you have
from abnormalities big big tongue tardy
let me see it
yeah that's it down syndrome yeah yeah
let me see
and i'm a pcs pediatric certified
especially so i have the doctorate
degree in physical therapy but then
furthermore pcs
so i could clinically tell you legally
that's down syndrome tongue a dst
wow and i'm not offended by it thank you
for validating mine you say it again
dst down syndrome thank you you're
welcome absolutely
what else is don syndrome about me
they're typically
uh usually because of the chromosomal
abnormality a bit overweight
um on the smaller side
you usually lifespan is to about 60.
um and uh and
instigate the instigators they're
they're all instigators no
i'm kidding no the last part i'm kidding
but but you do you do
have uh a lot of but no qualities okay
okay
please there's a comedy line
and you're right again right but that's
what good comedians i understand but
then you had crossed over
which which particularly [ __ ] pissed
me off which part questions don't have
down syndrome
okay no no no i've never done a dna test
i'm almost positive i'm almost positive
i don't have it
okay i have it no i can drive
i can drive okay yeah i know when i
watch i know how to stream things
on you know can they do that yes oh they
can
some of them can because they have good
therapy yeah yeah yeah can they can they
um
do you have a pretty good kd on when
they play warzone on uh uh
yeah i mean one i was yeah we had a
really high functioning short necks
small ears
there you go latin face of course but
that's because i'm asian that's not fair
yeah
i'm in shape it's not flat yeah yeah
right
almond shade that's not fair are they
just describing asian
no but bobby it's a compliment because
it's uh you know uh
working with all types of children with
disabilities down syndrome children
children with down syndrome are
beautiful friendly no
the friendliest children just truly out
of out of the uh you know and that's
also a characteristic
of children with downstream is they're
very friendly and outgoing you're very
friendly and outgoing
and you you know and that's and that's
what it is so so i
i would say this bobby let me say this
as a clinical yeah as a clinical
therapist you're talking i'm actually
you know it's silly but i i am i am
technically
at least in the state of new york
legally not saying what i'm saying
is you don't have down syndrome but you
have many characteristics that are
and i'm fine with that consistent with
down syndrome and i'm fine with that i
would say you're consistent with
downtown
i'm fine with it i'm fine with it okay
all right all i want to know is
could you do pt on me yes and that's all
i want to know yes
okay what whatever ailment you may have
anybody in the room like back like
i have bad problems my shoulders hurt
sometimes typically back stuff
yeah yeah is usually it's it's usually
your back is flexed too far forward
because of phones and sitting in cars in
our in a bad position
so it's usually the answer is getting
this posture spine into neutral
and then a little extension is usually
the answer
kyphosis is kyphosis is when you flex
forward lordosis is flexed
that's what it is have you thought of
because i know you do like a lot of
reality shows didn't you you did you had
a deal to do a sitcom right
you came out here chrissy pilots